if you love frozen as much as we do
you're probably fed up of waiting for
its sequel to come out well looks like
you'll have to wait a little longer but
don't worry we have something that'll
tie you over until then watch until the
end to find out why Kristen Bell will be
getting less screen time in frozen - are
you a Disney fan if so don't forget to
give us a big thumbs up and subscribe to
the things for more great content now
let's dive into the ten dark secrets
about frozen - Disney doesn't want you
to know the release date if there's one
thing every Disney fan can agree on
it's that frozen is one of the best
animated movies of all time the world
was hit by a craze the very second it
came out into theaters and its sequel
shouldn't be any different well it may
be hard to believe that it's been six
years since frozen's initial release
it's the truth this is confirmed by the
fact that Rosen - is rapidly approaching
a theater near you when fans first hot
wind of a sequel they immediately began
searching the internet for release dates
and inside information
however the Disney production did
everything they could to keep their
plans under wrap when it comes to
actress Kristen Bell however she's
comfortable giving us the inside scoop
during an interview the Astra souffles
Anna revealed that the frozen tooth
production was moving on rather slowly
the reason behind this being that Disney
wanted to release a sequel that made the
original proud since blowing their
standards to release frozen - on time
isn't an option were left here waiting
on the sidelines Belle also spoke about
why Disney took so long
to announce the sequel stating that they
want a direction before the entire world
caught up with their intentions with
everything going on it's only normal
that it took about six years for Disney
to perfect the most anticipated sequel
of all time your powers really are
beautiful Elsa Kristen Bell couldn't
wait to work with Sterling Kay brown
when you're rich and famous you
basically run with a different crowd
with this in mind it's sometimes hard to
believe that stars can get starstruck by
celebrated actors and singers - by now
most of us love Kristen Bell or at least
know one or two of her movies which
pretty much makes her a worldwide
celebrity regardless of this there's one
actor she can't seem to keep her cool
around when Belle found out that
sterling K Brown would possibly be
joining in on frozen - he basically
started to jump for joy though went as
far as telling reporters that she loves
her son sterling and would rock it to
the moon if she got to work with him
turns out her wish came true because
months later Disney confirmed that Brown
would be joining the frozen - cast
Brown auditioned for one of the new lead
roles and obviously director saw
something that they liked while Disney
has kept Brown's character top secret
many of us are just happy to hear that
he's on board are you excited to find
what this actors mysterious role will be
we sure are after all he could
potentially become the king of arendelle
The Snow Queen was 70 years in the
making coming up with the storyline like
frozen
isn't an easy thing to do in fact it
took Disney years before deciding to
actually give this movie ago however
like most great films the frozen
storyline wasn't invented it was
inspired by a previously existing story
have you ever heard of The Snow Queen
story if so you probably know it took
Disney a total of 70 years to make a
movie adaptation of this great novel
Hans Christian Andersen and it dates all
the way back to the Snow White era like
most Disney movies frozen is based off
of a dark and devastating story
regardless of this Disney writers and
animators always find a way to turn it
into something light and inspiring have
any of you noticed how Disney movies are
keeping up with the times whereas once
they told tales of gallant heroes and
frightened damsels they're now
encouraged
women to stand on their own two feet in
the end Disney chose to go with their
guts and create a modern-day fairy tale
about two sisters and we're not
complaining we're just curious to see
what frozen to has in store for us we're
honest personality came from when a
writer creates a script they have a
certain image of what their character
will be like funny enough princess Ana's
character was supposed to be a lot
different than the one we know and love
instead of being a quirky and headstrong
character she was written as a young
girl with a princess complex when
actress Kristen Bell was cast as Ana she
couldn't help but feel like something
was wrong whereas she would normally
connect with her character she just
couldn't seem to get on board with her
so when it all came down to was her
needing some creative freedom instead of
going by the book Bella used her own
personality to influence on us luckily
for her directors were happy with the
switch and even encouraged it in order
to help animators create the perfect Ana
cameras were set to film Belle as she
read her lines this allowed them to
mimic Belle's facial expressions and
body language all in all honor wouldn't
be the bubbly character she is if Belle
hadn't been casted can you imagine
having to deal with a preppy princess or
we sure can't keep watching to find out
why Anna and Elsa might bump heads in
the sequel the internet is going wild
with theories if there's one thing
everyone gets tired of it's waiting long
periods of time for something they want
right now most frozen fans know exactly
how this feels especially since they've
been patiently waiting for a sequel
since 2013 so what do people do when
they're looking forward to something
they start trying to piece the puzzle
together themselves
ever since Disney announced that frozen
two would be hitting the big screen fans
have been losing their marbles to keep
themselves occupied they've been
creating some pretty wild fan theories
sure fan theories might be a little
far-fetched but they're also a lot of
fun a good thing to keep in mind though
is to never get your hopes up because we
never know what the sequel holds after
browsing the internet for theories it's
pretty clear that fans are going a
little dark
since frozen left on a good note fans
expect the sequel to take a turn for the
worst some fans believe that Elsa and
Olaf will become an item by the end of
the movie however other
think that this beloved character will
say his final goodbyes
Wow there's no way of knowing if any of
these theories are true there is one
thing that's for certain
the Internet is going crazy do you have
any frozen two theories if so drop them
in the comments and see if anyone agrees
with you Zootopia is riddled with frozen
- references as many of you already know
Disney loves to make some low-key cameos
in their films this is why various
Disney objects and characters can be
spotted in a scenes backgrounds from
time to time three years ago after
frozen came out in theaters Disney
released Zootopia while everything
seemed normal at first glance some fans
realized that Zootopia was actually
riddled with frozen - references while
this could be a coincidence it's
definitely meant to rile up the frozen
fans around the world throughout the
movie young animal children are seen
wearing similar Elsa and Anna outfits
around town in addition chief BOGO is
also seen telling Judy to let it go when
she takes her duties a little too far so
let it go if this isn't enough for you
there's also a scene when a mock cover
of what appears to be frozen - is being
sold at Dukes movie shop however this
time it goes by the name of floats into
all this to say that Disney is laughing
as we twiddle our thumbs while waiting
for November 27 2019 to arrive we don't
know about you but we're growing
impatient which character are you most
excited to see come 2019 Kristen Bell is
patiently waiting for the movie to come
out last time we checked in with Kristen
Bell she was starting to get excited
about voicing Ana's lines however months
passed before she was actually able to
start working on the project
now that frozen Sue's release date is
almost a year away Bell has some new
information for us in April of 2018
the actress appeared on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show where she confirmed that
she'd recently finished recording frozen
- the gifted actress made sure to tell
us that edits would eventually be made
but for the most part filming was
complete if there's one thing Belle
didn't hesitate to say is that she knew
how the movie would end
and which songs would undoubtedly become
bangers since keeping secrets is in her
strong suits val is as excited as we are
to see the movie come to life cell also
went on to say that her youngest
daughter isn't exactly a fan of the
franchise while she blames it on her age
some people just aren't up for building
a snowman despite having many reasons to
get excited over frozen to is released
it's still a while away so hold your
horses frozen to isn't your typical
Disney sequel when you think about it
frozen is one of the most unique Disney
movies of all there are obviously plenty
to choose from but Queen Elsa is the
only Disney character to possess mutant
my qualities shear Rapunzel has her
magical hair and Cinderella has a fairy
godmother but Elsa is the real deal
through and through and it's uncommon
for Disney movies to get a sequel
however it is common for these sequels
to go straight to DVD with this in mind
it's quite astonishing that frozen 2 is
predicted to be as successful as its
original it makes this sequel even more
special is that it's not going to follow
frozen timeline with this in mind
there's no way of knowing just what's
going to happen
Disney has stated that the direction of
frozen 2 will be 100% different and by
this they mean that a new protagonist is
going to take the stage when a sequel
makes it to the box office this usually
means that the same protagonists are
going to be used so with this in mind
frozen 2 is breaking all of the rules
but wait who's going to be the front
liner move over Anna
here comes Elsa just as we thought
frozen 2 is making way for Elsa's grand
debut despite the fact that Elsa was
present in the first frozen movie we
couldn't help a wish that we'd gotten to
know her on a more personal level well
you're in luck because Elsa is said to
be the main protagonist of the sequel
now that the ice queen has come to terms
with her powers she's bound to want to
start building her future co-director
Chris buck made it clear that the sequel
would shift its focus away from Anna and
Kristoff and on to Elsa and whoever she
ends up with despite undergoing a major
transformation in frozen Elsa still has
a long way to go truth is there's so
much about Elsa that we don't know maybe
we'll finally find out where her
mysterious powers come from now that
it's been confirmed that Elsa is taking
over this makes us wonder about Ana's
role
and influence throughout the film and
mainly whether or not Kristen Bell is
going to get a good amount of screen
time for the time being it looks like
Elsa and Anna will be bumping heads for
the number one spot so who's your
favorite sister Elsa or Anna nothing
will ever top let it go
once again our only news source is the
hilarious Kristen Bell the actress came
clean about frozen - while being
interviewed by E News she spoke about
how grateful she was to her fans for
allowing her to continue her frozen
journey as Anna she also mentioned that
there were more frozen songs out there
than Disney previously led on since only
the best songs are chosen there's a few
that got placed on the back burner which
pretty much means we'll never hear them
during the interview Bell spoke of the
sequel soundtrack with a high volume of
enthusiasm however when asked if any of
his songs with top let it go the actress
simply laughed
according to her no song will ever top
this acclaimed track there's just no way
she does however feel like frozen tube
will be jam-packed with some glorious
hits for the time being we'd love to get
our hands on the unreleased soundtrack
after all do you want to build a snowman
almost didn't make a cut which frozen
song was your favorite drop us a lyric
in the comments if you're excited for
frozen - and that's a wrap we hope
you're even more excited for frozen -
than before thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]